hello we've finally gotten our first
look at it chapter 2 the follow-up to
the 2017 movie this installment is based
on the second half of Stephen King's
classic novel here's everything in the
trailer you might have missed at the end
of the first movie
Beverly revealed she had a vision of the
losers Club reuniting as adults to fight
penny wise once more I saw all of us
together back history we were older they
swore a blood oath that if he ever were
to resurface and dairy they'd return to
destroy him once and for all as we know
Pennywise revisits a town every 27 years
so that's when the new movie picks back
up the trailer opens with Beverly paying
a visit to her childhood home in Derry
where there now lives an old lady named
mrs. Kirsch it becomes clear that mrs.
Kirsch is actually the shape-shifting
Pennywise he's assuming a form inspired
by the witch and Hansel and grettel
based on Beverly's childhood fear of
that character
the so called mrs. Kirsch complains
about the sweltering heat I do apologize
it gets so very hot here this time of
year it's fine and mentions that she has
cookies in the oven I had some cookies
in the oven before you came
both are direct references to the German
fairy tale in which the witch tries to
make Gretel climb into her oven to see
if it's hot enough when the sweating old
lady unbuttons her blouse she reveals a
grizzly chest wound it's probably
leftover from when Mike impaled
Pennywise with a fence post
meanwhile Beverly has some bruising
around her wrists if this part of the
movie sticks to the book those bruises
could be from Beverly's abusive
boyfriend Tom who fought her when she
announced she had to return to Derry you
might have also noticed mrs. Kirsch's
peculiar pronunciation of the word
father my father came to this country
with 14 dollars in his pocket my father
joined the circus this is a direct
reference to the book in which Kirsch
explains that her family emigrated from
Sweden hence the accent soon mrs. Kirsch
makes a reference to one of Beverly's
childhood traumas are you still his
little girl Beverly mrs. Kirsch /
Pennywise is repeating something
Beverly's abusive father said to her in
the 2017 film notice Beverly drinks from
the Kop mrs. Kirsch build for her she
does the same in the book only to
realize that she hadn't been served tea
but sewer excrement it's unclear if
that's what she's drinking here
but knowing penny wise it's probably
nothing tasty once Beverly manages to
escape the door changes from saying
Kirsch to Marsh Beverly's own last name
you might remember this Paul Bunyan
statue from the 2017 movie it's likely
this eerie statue will figure
prominently in the new film in the book
Pennywise takes the form of the Bunyan
statue to attack Richie almost killing
at one point we get a fleeting shot of
Beverley drowning in a pool of blood it
looks like this scene takes place in the
school bathroom it echoes this scene
from the 2017 film which recreates a
part of the novel in which Pennywise
spews buckets of blood all over
Beverly's bathroom we also see brief
clips of the losers Club meeting at a
Chinese restaurant this likely means
we'll see the scene from the original
miniseries in which each character opens
a fortune cookie with their fears hidden
inside it chapter 2 hits theaters
September 6 2019 until then did you
catch anything we missed
let us know in the comments
[Music]